[Music]  it's alarming how charming  I feel Melissa McCarthy is back on  Saturday Night Live this weekend hosting  her fifth episode oh my god this is  McCarthy's official induction into SNL's  five timers Club her first time hosting  was back in October 2011 a huge fan of  the show so this is an absolute dream  come true for me  her famed impression of White House  press secretary Sean Spicer will return  and is getting a lot of buzz online I'm  not here to be your buddy I'm here to  swallow gum and I'm here to take Nate on  Friday McCarthy was spotted by ETS own  Michelle Turner in full speiser mode  taking the signature podium into the  bustling streets of New York City  traffic  you